MIKE: We're going through the
house, buying a lot of stuff,
and Steve and I haven't
forgot about the tandem deal.
All right, I've been thinking
about the bike a lot.
STEVE: OK.
MIKE: So your
grandfather made this?
STEVE: He had a master
welder at one point.
MIKE: I was going to
say, because-- man,
I mean, if you look at the--
the-- the lug work
and everything--
STEVE: He wouldn't-- he
wouldn't have done that himself.
Yeah, sure.
MIKE: You can't ride
this bike by yourself.
You have to have two
people to balance it.
So you know, forget about all
the dating apps out there.
You know, you really
want to challenge
somebody on the first date?
Get them on something like this.
Whoa!
It's fixed gear.
It's direct drive.
There's no brakes!
If you're riding on
the boardwalk, you--
[laughter] you kind
of don't need them.
FRANK: You've got
to-- you've got
to be in sync with your person.
- Yeah.
Well, yeah-- but you just
got to-- you got to control--
control it with
your legs, you know.
Right.
MIKE: Now, over the years, the
rims have been changed out.
The pedals are different.
The seats are different.
So when I'm looking at
this, I'm looking at it
from like a novelty aspect.
It's interesting.
It's different, but, like,
as far as collecting goes,
this is not a big money bike.
Is it desirable?
Yes, it is to the right person.
I-- I'm thinking like--
I don't know, like
maybe 300 bucks.
[music playing]
I was thinking 400.
I think 3 is a little low.
MIKE: How about 350 on it?
How about I meet
you halfway at 375?
MIKE: You like it, Frankie?
I like it.
I-- I've never seen one before.
See, he's not even a
bike guy, and he likes it.
So 375.
Done.
MIKE: I appreciate it.
There's a little bit of
room on the back end.
But what I want to do is
push that story forward.
This is from a family, three
generations, bicycle shop--
this is something
that's going to be
fresh onto the market for a
bicycle collector to enjoy.
Take that.
There you go.
I got this.
STEVE: I know that they have
an appreciation for this stuff.
Take it easy on the toys.
You got Frankie's
treasure chest.
Steve's been walking
through memory lane today.
And honestly, it's been
like that for me too.
FRANK: Steve, we appreciate it.
Thank you both.
MIKE: You feel connected
on a lot of these picks,
but today was extra
special for me.
[honking]
Roll on, Steve!
Thanks, guys.